nate c'est grâce c'est une nouvelle patronne ravie
de vous rencontrer je perdrais une égalité si j'étais
vous
ici nous allons
rappelez-vous que vous n'êtes pas leur parent vous êtes
un autre thérapeute vous êtes ici pour créer
un environnement sûr et c'est
tout vous  mieux vaut ne rien faire
ted
j'ai toujours voulu travailler avec
des enfants défavorisés
marcus s'installer les
fleurs représentent les pensées particulières
qui sortent de ton esprit magnifique
tout ce qui est bien dans ma vie est grâce à
toi
je connais les règles pas de ceintures pas de contremarches pas de
ciseaux pas de [ __ ]  la liberté pas de
merde de jurons j'ai oublié celle-là
j'ai dit à son père que nous prenions bien soin d'
elle la semaine dernière elle ferait mieux de nouvelles de thérapeute
wow elle a l'air d'être une fille vraiment sympa
joyeux anniversaire
ton père sort de prison dans une
semaine
tu veux entendre une histoire  j'ai
travaillé sur
je suis sur le sol tous les jours avec ces
enfants ce n'est pas votre travail d'interpréter les
larmes
une seule fois suivez les conseils que vous donnez à vos
enfants et apprenez à parler de ce qui se
passe dans votre tête
grâce
c'est mon  petit gâteau